that's the thing about fallout it's a
world bereft of beauty of color or life
but such is the power of that world but
there are a few other places we'd rather
spend days and weeks and months
exploring so Bethesda was in your court
six weeks to e3 it was a favor there's
millions of us ready waiting to go back
to the waistline oh hello there vault
dweller have you been has a really been
a year since we last spoke what have you
been up to oh that's very interesting me
I've been wandering the wasteland you
know killing Raiders hunting Brahman
wandering the endless horizon alone I
got a fat boy though at one stage I was
there was a lot of fun I enjoyed that
gave me awful welts on my back and ran
out of ammunition had to toss it you
know how encumbrance works in this post
apocalypse of ours still though I like
my new humble abode here on the East
Coast lots of new things to see and do
lots of trees got all these trees I miss
trees and my Irish accent seems to go
down a lot better with these locals
still though there's lots to learn about
this new place so why don't we learn
together
hey mysterious stranger the point season
3 episode 14 fallout 4 secrets of the
new apocalypse okay first things first
it seems all those leaks were true
fallout 4 does take place in Boston but
it looks unlike any fallout city we've
seen before
unlike DC or New Vegas the Boston and
fallout seems to have survived the
nuclear apocalypse rather well blocks
upon blocks of buildings still stand the
statue of Paul Revere and Bunker Hill
Monument remained relatively unscathed
scholary square lives on even the USS
Constitution a vessel made out of timber
seems to have survived pretty well must
have been the same guy who built dinky
the t-rex and speaking of green monsters
Fenway Park has been converted into
diamond city a new township housing a
noodle bar and a baseball memorabilia
store while chemic air will likely
soothe your longing for jet it's one
part of a city that looks much more
formed than livable than what we've seen
before
perhaps the wastelanders here
much more connected with our culture and
heritage than those who emerged on the
west coast outside of Boston in the
wider world which we can safely assume
as New England sites are much more
familiar broken electrical pylons
shattered highways territorial mirelurks
Brahmin caravans roaming protected ron's
vertibirds
and mr. handy pouring out sugar bombs a
baby's mobile made out of repconn
rockets perhaps even wandering
deathclaws to run away from for the
first 10 hours of the game some people
have criticized this world for not being
pretty enough ooh has superficial of you
but you know it's not the fabric that
makes the garment it's the stitching but
for that you have to look much much
closer what do we see well first of all
whether in previous Fallout games the
only way to get rain was by installing
mods but this trailer features a vast
array of weather effects wandering rain
clouds thunderstorms there are clear
skies sandstorms and fog will this
wetter affect gameplay wildlife or
combat is there acid rain we have much
still to learn another clue to your role
in this world are the words on the
fallout 4 website
welcome home hangs outside the
now-familiar gas station from the
trailer a gas station with
work-in-progress power armor being
pieced together a station with weapon
components on the wall a place to put
your bobble heads and even a magazine
rack all this points towards it being
your home area a spot to craft and store
your items a safe haven from where you
build your own set of power armor and
for you and your dog to rest your weary
legs so we know where but when does this
all take place perhaps the biggest clue
is the GNN poster fan in this clip the
voice actor behind galaxy news radios
three dog accidentally leaked that he
was back for fallout 4 over 2 years ago
could galaxy news radio have expanded
into galaxy news network in any case if
three dog is still alive and kicking it
can't be that far ahead in the future so
if it's also post apocalyptic then why
is all this stuff from the past in their
content is the most expensive part of
game development creating people and
things in places so what Bethesda really
spend all that time creating houses and
retro looking cars and people from the
2077 time line on
was label perhaps a prologue maybe
something a bit more substantive this is
where it gets interesting friends at the
end of the trailer when the player
character spoke the words let's go pal
it all but confirmed the reports in
Kotaku is 2013 story in which they
claimed that the character would be
voiced that same initial leak that said
the game was going to be said in Boston
this all coming from casting called
documents obtained and published by the
site and when we look back at these
documents they reveal some very
interesting details the original opening
script contained a player character
whose great-grandfather fought in world
war ii the player character being voiced
spoke of the incoming war and how he was
afraid for his wife and his infant son
the war he's speaking of is a war of
2077 which turned America into a
wasteland two hundred years before the
events of fallout 3 so if we are to
believe that these documents are true
that not only is this the family we saw
in the trailer but this man is
controlled by the player
meaning pre-war elements of the game
will actually be playable this casting
call also had scripts for male and
female voices possibly the descendants
of the soldier in 2077 or maybe somebody
unrelated a side story unveiled by a
custom character that is played over the
course of the game a game told from the
perspective of two characters divided by
two hundred years of nuclear death but
the biggest rumor hanging over fallout 4
isn't when it's set but when we'll be
able to play it if they follow the
release schedule of Skyrim which came
out eleven months after it was initially
revealed then sooner rather than later
Bethesda certainly revealed a lot more
than their far-flung teaser trailers
usually do a popular reddit thread this
week which was posted last year
apparently by somebody fired from
Bethesda also points towards a 2015
release but then most of what this
redditor claims was actually already
going through the rumor mill at the time
it was posted so this is actually just
likely random speculation regardless
common sense would put good caps on that
long rumor 2015 release date it would
certainly explain why it's already
available to pre-order on
and in the meantime there's so many more
questions about this new wasteland those
vats return is their dynamic leveling do
the Yankees still exist so many more
questions and so many more answers to
look forward to but while we wait for
them
let me first say thank you to all those
folks at Bethesda you've made this vault
dweller and millions more around the
world very happy indeed it's time to
stock up on right away a little buddy
it's time to go back to the wasteland
you